اهلا بكم قال الريان عن الديوان الملكي
الاردنيه ان الملك عبد الله الثاني شدد
خلال لقاء الجماعه اليوم في عمان مع رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو على
ضروره احترام الوضع التاريخي والقانوني
القائم في الحرم القدسي الشريف وعدم
المساسبه حسب البيان هكذا العاهل الاردنيه
خلال اللقاء على ضروره الالتزام بالتهدئه
في اعمال العنف لفتح المجال امام افقا
سياسيه لعمليه السلام- وشدد الملك عبد
الله تاكيد على موقف الاردن الثابت الداعي
الى الالتزامه بحل دولتين بحيث يضمن قيام
دوله فلسطينيه مستقله وضروره استفاده
الجانب الفلسطيني من المشاريع الاقتصاديه
والاقليميه بحسب البيع
ومن جاتا سريع قال بيانو ديوان رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي الذي الزعيمين
ناقش القضايا الاقليميه وتعزيز التعاون
الاستراتيجيه والامنيه والاقتصادي بين
اسرائيل والاردن بما يساهموا في استقرار
المنطقه كما بارك الصداقه وشراكه الطويله
الامد بين اسرائيل والاردن نقلت وسائل
الاعلام اسرائيليه ان نتنياهو تعهد خلال
لقائه العاهل الاردني بالحفاظ على الوطن
التاريخي والقانوني للمسجد الاقصى